>> MY DEAR FRIENDS, AND BELOVED
COLLEAGUE IS HERE AT CNN JOINS
ME NOW FOR A VERY PERSONAL
STORY.
TODAY, AS YOU MAY HAVE SEEN,
SARA SIDNER BRAVELY REVEALED
THAT SHE IS BEING TREATED FOR
STAGE THREE BREAST CANCER.
RATHER THAN FIGHT THIS BATTLE
PRIVATELY, SHE IS SHARING HER
STORY, HOPE IT MAKES MORE WOMEN,
PARTICULARLY BLACK WOMEN PAY
ATTENTION TO THEIR OWN HEALTH.
I SARA, THANKS FOR STAYING UP
LATE WITH US.
I KNOW IT HAS BEEN QUITE A DAY.
HOW ARE YOU FEELING?
>> TODAY WAS REALLY
UNCOMFORTABLE.
[LAUGHTER]
I KNOW THAT SOUNDS REALLY WEIRD,
YOU WOULD THINK CHEMO IS THE
MOST UNCOMFORTABLE THING, IT IS
POISON, BUT IT IS THERE TO HELP
YOU SURVIVE.
I AM NOT USED TO TALKING ABOUT
MY PERSONAL BUSINESS.
IN OUR FAMILY, WHICH I HAVE
DISCUSSED, THE THING THAT IS
SAID OVER AND OVER AGAIN ON
BOTH SIDES OF MY FAMILY'S DON'T
TELL YOUR PERSONAL BUSINESS.
IT'S NOT ANYBODY'S BUSINESS,
KEEP IT YOURSELF.
SO, I HAD TO UNDO THAT'S
BECAUSE I THOUGHT THAT IT WAS
IMPORTANT THAT BECAUSE OF THE
NUMBERS, BECAUSE PARTICULARLY
THE NUMBERS FOR WOMEN AND THEN
EVEN MORE SPECIFICALLY FOR
BLACK WOMEN I NEEDED TO SAY
SOMETHING.
>> YEAH.
I WANT TO GET TO THAT IN A
SECOND BECAUSE IT IS SO
IMPORTANT.
YOU FOUND OUT AT, I CANNOT EVEN
DESCRIBE IT, IT WAS A BUSY
TIME.
>> YES.
>> IT IS ALWAYS EASY FOR YOU
BUT IT WAS A VERY BUSY TIME.
YOU ARE IN A WAR ZONE
REPORTING.
WHAT WAS NOT LIKE?
>> IT WAS JUST BEFORE.
I HAD NOTICED A LUMP.
AND, THEN I THOUGHT IT WENT
AWAY, AND SO I KIND OF PLAYED
THIS MIND GAME WITH MYSELF THAT
MAYBE THAT WAS JUST AN ANOMALY.
JUST BEFORE THE WAR HAD BROKEN
OUT ON OCTOBER 7TH, I KNEW THAT
I HAD A LUMP AND I HAD DONE A
MAMMOGRAM AND I WENT ANYWAY
BECAUSE I WAS NOT SURE WHAT IT
WAS AND THEY SAID OKAY YOU NEED
TO COME BACK FOR A BIOPSY.
I WAS LIKE OKAY, WAS THAT THE
RIGHT CHOICE, I DO NOT KNOW.
BUT, IT IS SORT OF TYPICAL OF
ME TO GO AND DO THE JOB THAT I
FEEL LIKE THE BEST PLACE I'M
SUPPOSED TO BE FOR THE COMPANY
FOR THE STORY AND I HAVE TO
TELL YOU THAT'S BEING THERE AT
A TIME WHEN I WAS ALMOST 100%
SURE I WAS GOING TO COME BACK
AND FIND OUT I HAD CANCER IT'S
REALLY SHIFTED MY THOUGHT WHAT
PEOPLE WERE GOING THROUGH THEIR,
SEEING WHAT'S HAPPENING TO
PEOPLE IN ISRAEL AFTER A HAMAS
ATTACK AND THEN SEEING WHAT
HAPPENED TO PEOPLE IN GAZA AND
LIVING THROUGH THAT AND
WATCHING THEM TRY TO SURVIVE
SOMETHING THAT FRANKLY IS FAR
WORSE THAN ANYTHING I HAVE BEEN
DIAGNOSED WITH, AT THE POINT OF
ANYTHING I WOULD BE DIAGNOSED
WITH LATER IT HAS TAUGHT ME
THAT LIVING IS THE ULTIMATE AND
THAT'S NOTHING ELSE MATTERS.
IT'S REALLY SET MY HEAD
STRAIGHT WHEN I GOT BACK AND
FOUR DAYS LATER AFTER I GOT MY
BIOPSY I FOUND I HAD STAGE
THREE BREAST CANCER.
>> YOU WANTED TO FIGHT.
YOU NEEDED TO FIGHT.
>> I SAW PEOPLE FIGHTING IN THE
WORST OF CIRCUMSTANCES.
PEOPLE HAVE CANCER THAT THEY'RE
IN GAZA RIGHT NOW.
PEOPLE HAVE CANCER THAT'S ARE
IN ISRAEL AND DEALING WITH THE
ATTACKS ON TO DEALING WITH THE
ROCKETS COMING OVER.
AND, THEY ARE STILL FIGHTING TO
LIVE.
SO, WHO AM I NOT TO DO THE SAME
THING IN A PLACE WHERE I HAVE
RESOURCES, I HAVE COMMUNITY,
AND I HAVE A LOT OF LOVE AND
CARE?
THIS IS BY NO MEANS A WAR ZONE,
SO, I FELT LIKE IT WAS ALMOST
MY DUTY TO GO FORWARD AND DO
THIS.
>> YOU CAME BACK AND YOU
MENTIONED EARLIER AND IN YOUR
MESSAGE TODAY THE STATISTICS
FOR BLACK WOMEN WHEN IT COMES
TO BREAST CANCER ARE SO AWFUL.
DID YOU EVEN KNOW ABOUT THAT?
>> I HAD NO IDEA.
I KNEW THERE WAS A DISPARITY.
I HAD NO IDEA.
I WENT ON A RABBIT HOLE, AS WE
ALL DO, I KNOW YOU KNOW THIS
BECAUSE AS SOON AS YOU FIND
SOMETHING OUT YOU RESEARCH.
SO, EVERY NIGHT I WAS LOOKING
AT RESEARCHING AND IT WAS LIKE
THAT I READ THAT RIGHT, I HAD
TO READ IT THREE OR FOUR TIMES
THAT ONE IN EIGHT WOMEN WILL
GET BREAST CANCER IN THEIR
LIFETIME.
THOSE ARE THE STATISTICS.
, SO I CAN NAME EIGHT WOMEN
RIGHT NOW AND IT IS COMPLETELY
BLOWS MY MIND THAT ONE OF US IS
GOING TO GET IT.
I AM THE ONE IN MY GROUP.
BUT, THEN I WENT FURTHER AND
I'M LIKE 41%, THAT IS HOW MUCH
MORE LIKELY YOU ARE TO DIE IF
YOU HAPPEN TO BE A BLACK WOMAN.
WHAT THE ARE WE DOING?
THAT SHOULD NOT BE TRUE.
BLACK WOMEN DO NOT GET PRESS
COUNCIL MORE THAN WHITEWAY MAN,
THEY GENERALLY IS NOT A HIGHER
INSTANCE, BUT THE DEATH RATE IS
SO SEVERE.
>> THEY ARE MORE LIKELY TO HAVE,
TO FIND OUT ABOUT IT WHEN IT IS
AT A MORE ADVANCED STAGE, WHICH
CAN BE SO CRITICAL.
I MEAN, SOMEONE RAISED TO ME
THAT WHEN WOMEN HAVE TO DECIDE
HOW THEY TREAT THEIR HEALTH
PREVENTATIVELY, WHAT DO YOU
WANT THEM TO UNDERSTAND ABOUT
WHY THIS MATTERS, TO GO THAT
EXTRA STEP AND GET THAT
MAMMOGRAM?
TO TAKE THAT MOMENT AND DON'T
LOOK PAST THE LUMP YOU FEEL.
>> I MEAN, I'M GUILTY OF DOING
THAT.
HERE I AM, RIGHT?
STAGE THREE.
HAVE I LISTEN TO MYSELF IN THE
VERY BEGINNING, I PROBABLY
WOULD'VE BEEN BETTER OFF.
BUT, I QUESTION MYSELF AND WAS
LIKE OH, I DIDN'T REALLY WANT
TO HEAR IT.
THE TRUTH IS, I THINK A LOT OF
US ARE AFRAID, A LOT OF US HAVE
HAD ISSUES WITH HEALTH CARE AND
THE KELP CARE INDUSTRY WHEN IT
COMES TO BEING A WOMAN AND ON
TOP OF THAT A BLACK WOMAN.
ISSUES WITH NOT BEING BELIEVED.
SO, THERE ARE LOTS OF THINGS
THAT SORT OF MAKE YOU NOT
REALLY WANT TO KNOW.
BUT, PLEASE, FOR GOD SAKES.
DO THE SELF EXAM.
THAT'S HOW I CAUGHT IT, AND
THEN THE MONOGRAM.
DO EVERYTHING YOU CAN DO
BECAUSE THIS IS NOT YOUR
GRANDMOTHER'S CANCER TREATMENTS
ANYMORE.
THAT IS THE ONE THING I WANT
PEOPLE TO KNOW.
IF YOU HAPPEN TO BE DIAGNOSED,
AND GOD FORBID, BUT IF YOU
HAPPEN TO BE DIAGNOSED, I AM
STILL WORKING OUT, I'M STILL
RUNNING, I AM STILL WORKING, I
AM STILL HERE WITH YOU TONIGHT,
I'M STILL HANGING OUT WITH MY
FAMILY, LAUGHING, JOKING, DOING
ALL THE THINGS AND LIVING MY
LIFE.
IS IT HARD?
YES.
DO I HAVE FATIGUE SOMETIMES?
DO I HAVE NOT DONE SOMETIMES?
YES.
THEY HAVE FIGURED OUT
INCREDIBLE WAYS TO DEAL WITH
ALL OF THE PAIN AND DISCOMFORT
THAT PEOPLE HAVE GONE THROUGH
THROUGHOUT THE DECADES IN WAYS
THAT NOW, EVEN BETTER THAN TEN
YEARS AGO.
SO, I JUST WANT PEOPLE TO
UNDERSTAND THAT IT IS NOT A
DEATH SENTENCE.
IT DOES NOT HAVE TO BE.
BUT, YOU HAVE TO LEARN SELF
CARE AND THAT IS MY LESSON.
SELF CARE IS IMPORTANT.
>> AS YOU FACE THIS NEXT STEP,
IT IS NOT OVER BUT YOU'RE
FACING IT INCREDIBLY BRAVELY.
YOU SAID TODAY THAT YOU ARE THE
HAPPIEST THAT YOU HAVE BEEN IN
DECADES.
HOW DO YOU FIND THAT PLACE OF
HAPPINESS AND JOY AND ALL OF
THIS?
>> I THINK THE ULTIMATE THINK
IS SO OFTEN I WOULD WAKE UP,
AND I THINK A LOT OF US DO THIS,
YOU HAVE A CHECKLIST.
YOU HAVE THINGS YOU MUST DO.
YOU ARE WORRYING ABOUT WHETHER
IT'S GETTING YOURSELF A,
GETTING YOUR KIDS, UP GOING TO
WORK, MAKE SURE YOU HAVE ALL
THE THINGS ON, THE DISH, IS
THAT THIS, THE CAR, THE BAD,
AND YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT ALL
THE TORIES YOU HAVE TO DO AND
THE MUMMY STRESSED OUT THE GAME
ALL THE THINGS I NEEDED TO
ACHIEVE THAT DAY.
WHEN WE COME IN THE MORNING NOW,
I AM JUST THANKFUL TO BE AWAKE.
LITERALLY WHEN I WAS SEVEN AND
EIGHT YEAR OLD WHEN YOU WOKE UP
EXCITED, I WAKE UP EXCITED.
I GET TO COME TO WORK TODAY, I
DO NOT FEEL SICK.
I GET TO GO WORK OUT TODAY, I
GET TO SEE MY FRIENDS, I GOT TO
HANG OUT ABBY PHILIP, I GET TO
TALK TO PEOPLE WHO ARE IN
CREDIBLE MINDS ON A DAILY
BASIS.
I JUST MY BRAIN HAS CHANGED AND
I AM SO FILLED WITH GRATITUDE,
FILLED TO THE BRIM WITH
GRATITUDE.
I HONESTLY HAD TO ONE MORNING
WAKE UP AND GO, YOU KNOW WHAT'S,
THANK YOU, CANCER, BECAUSE I
DID NOT SEE LIFE LIKE THIS
BEFORE AND I DO.
NOW >> SARA SIDNER, THANK